foreign
[Music]
ERS breakfast thousands of paramedics
call handlers Emergency Care assistants
and technicians in England and Wales are
on strike today the military has been
drafted in to help provide emergency
cover but NHS leaders warned the public
mustn't take risks with their safety and
only call 999 in a life-threatening
emergency the health secretary Steve
Barkley has accused unions of making a
conscious choice to inflict harm on
patients we'll be speaking to him in a
few minutes time will unions say that Mr
Barkley has been intransigent refusing
to negotiate over Bay let's bring in our
correspondent Dan Whitehead is joining
us now live from Bristol good morning to
you Dan so what's the situation where
you are
well across most of England and indeed
Wales picket lines are starting to form
as this strike by ambulance workers gets
underway we're at a picket line which is
being organized by one of the three
Unions that's carrying out this strike
action uh today this is the GMB at Union
more than 10 000 work as part of that
Union and ambulance services across nine
ambulance services are on the picket
lines today and we can have a quick chat
with the GMB union rep who's on the
picket line here Tim northover thanks
for speaking to us on Sky News Tim but
first of all just quickly outline the
main problems that the people you
represent are facing in the ambulance
service well first of all they faced
over a decade of real terms pay cut but
this is very much about pressures that
they're facing day in day out in terms
of the service so the service has been
subjects are Cuts we're currently facing
the highest levels of vacancies and
service the worst waiting times at a e
departments our members can't do their
jobs effectively because they often find
themselves stuck outside side anes all
day unable to hand over patients to to
the hospital is paid the major factor
here is there a percentage of an
increase in pay that your members would
be happy with well the government have
imposed around about four percent on
average for our members uh which is
again below inflation uh even prior to
this year our members have suffered
real-time cuts of up to 15 lagging
behind so we want to keep at least Pace
with inflation absolutely you're asking
for an inflation or above pay rise are
you actually expecting that in the
current climate well it's affordable I
haven't seen any data to suggest that a
pay rise for these essential workers
will damage the economy and very quickly
it's right that your guys are still
signing in at the ambulance station
around the corner aren't they uh they
will respond to to what sorts of
incidents yeah so the members of the GMB
represent do this job because they care
deeply about people so we're very
cognizant of our responsibilities to
provide life and limb cover so what that
looks like is that our members will sign
in right register as per normal and
respond if necessary from the picket
line for essential calls appreciate your
time Tim thanks so much we'll be
speaking to you and your members
throughout the morning quick word on the
Welsh government it is urging people not
to call 999 unless it is an absolute
emergency clearly Services throughout
today across England Wales are going to
be impacted
all right Dan in Bristol for now now we
have got correspondence across the
country covering this for us Fraser
Maude is in Burnley and Aisha zahid is
in Oxford for us this morning first to
you uh Fraser so tell us what's
happening up in Burnley how the Striking
workers there facing up to this morning
yeah here in Burnley uh three unions
involved in this industrial action unite
is one of those all the unite members uh
here in the Northwest are on strike
today so obviously services will be
pinched this is an unprecedented time of
pressure on the services talking to one
Ambulance Service yesterday they were
saying that a couple of days ago they
had the business 24 hours of the year in
terms of the number of requests for
ambulance call outs and those waiting
and so a lot of people left waiting and
more people are going to be left waiting
perhaps even longer today because of the
industrial action can talk to the unite
representative here Keith Hudson four
percent has been offered the government
think that's enough clearly your members
don't no I mean given the fact that
inflation's running around about 12
percent and given the fact that there's
been cuts to pay every year because it's
never met to inflation levels since
2010.
um people need a pay rise it's as simple
as that
but in terms of the the terms and
conditions as well I mean we've been
hearing for some time now about the
pressures that the ambulance service is
under what sort of pressures are you
facing what are the the biggest bug
bears that your staff face well because
of the way that the pay has gone people
have just left the ambulance service so
qualified well heavily qualified people
have just said well it's not enough it's
not worth it for the money so they've
left and drove so the staff in shortages
are unbearable so the you look at the
Staffing levels now compared to the
staff in levels say eight nine years ago
they're just starting the qualified
staff you know it takes five years to
train a paramedic they don't just come
off this production line after about 10
minutes they're qualified heavily
trained medical professionals here you
know you just don't get them off a
production line okay thanks very much
for talking to us so the situation so
bad that people are choosing to leave
the industry going into private Health
sector going into perhaps less skilled
jobs the pickets we'll be forming here
throughout the day a 24-hour strike here
as in many parts of the rest of the
country and people are being advised not
to take any unnecessary risks not to
dial 999 until unless it's an absolute
emergency
freighter thank you for now let's bring
in Aisha zaheed who's also joining us
live actually good morning to you and I
understand that you are in an area where
a critical incident has been called
yeah that's right South Central
ambulance service is just one of several
that have declared critical critical
incidents and these are separate from
the strike action most of them declared
yesterday it also includes South East
Coast Ambulance Service East of England
Northeast and Yorkshire ambulance
services what exactly is a critical
incident well it's an internal notice
issued which means that priority is then
refocused on those patients who are the
most ill it comes about due to demand
it's come about here because they've
faced unprecedented levels of demand
over the past week and that's paired up
with Hospital Handover delays which
doesn't help so to give you some context
in numbers here well at the same time
last year compared to now 999 calls have
increased by 50 and 111 calls have
increased by 75 they've described the
pressure over the course of the last
week as being extreme so the message
really is to only call 999 if it is a
life-threatening situation because of
course it won't be helped by the strain
felt by this strike action
Aisha Fraser and Dan thanks all
now if you scan that QR code that you
see right now at the bottom of your
screen that's going to take you to our
website where you can find out how the
strikes are affecting your area well
nearly all of the morning's newspapers
are leading with the strikes as you'd
expect the financial times goes with
warnings from NHS leaders that patient
safety cannot be guaranteed during these
strikes those safety concerns are also
the main focus of the eye the guardian
Echoes the message of NHS bosses saying
that they are now asking for the prime
minister to enter negotiations
the telegraph focuses on the health
secretary Steve Barkley saying that
unions are consciously making a decision
to inflict harm
the Metro headline you'd better watch
out while the times goes with this avoid
taking risks public told as paramedics
strike the star says that the advice
over what to do and what's not to do
amounts to wrapping the public in Cotton
wool while the sun says don't have fun
now the male asks a question to NHS
staff who are on strike saying how will
they live with themselves if people die
today
the mirror uses the struggle of NHS
stuff on strike to offer a comment on
the conservative pit Michelle moan while
the express tells us that military is
being deployed but as you can see their
main story is about the Christmas
post-royal fail they say
and to remind you that uh just after 10
past 17 a couple of minutes time we'll
be speaking to the health secretary
Steve Barkley then we'll be speaking to
the gmb's National secretary Rachel
Harrison at around half past seven
now Ukraine's President Vladimir
zaletsky is on his way to Washington he
sets to meet with Joe Biden at the White
House and make an address to Congress
it'll be the first time that zelenski
has left the country since Russia
invaded 10 months ago let's bring in our
International Affairs editor Dominic
guacorn is joining us now live good
morning to you Dom so surprised by this
are we that Mrs zelenski President
zielinski is on his way to DC
well I think for the last day or so it's
probably been the worst kept secret in
this war
um and we understand uh president
zielinski agreed to go a few days ago um
but it is now confirmed he is on his way
he said so on on Twitter and I think
it's a very big moment in this war
um he's taking a risk a security risk uh
you wouldn't want to overplay that the
fact is world leaders have have come to
Ukraine and gone and he's uh in the same
way able to go and then come back and
it's not as dangerous as what he did
yesterday when he went to the most
dangerous place on Earth probably back
much the town in the Easter in the Don
bass we went to a few days ago the sound
of constant shelling when we were there
and despite that he went there went to
the front line uh met the the troops
fighting on the front line and he
received a Ukrainian flag that many of
those soldiers have signed now he said
he's going to take that to Washington as
a hint to Americans to their leaders
that Ukraine needs more and he's going
there to press the need for strength and
resilience and I think it will be seen
the same lights as what Winston
Churchill did in the middle of The
Darkest Hours really of World War II in
1941 he took the risk of flying to
Washington and he also addressed both
houses of Congress and met the president
uh then and I think zelenski will be
using this visit to underline the knees
that ukrainians feel that the West
despite the billions of Aid they've been
given the huge amount of military
weapons still need more and the sense
here that the West has in particular
underestimated the damage that Vladimir
Putin can do to the civilian
infrastructure to the power supplies to
Ukraine we've driven through one major
city after another uh plunged into total
darkness hospitals threatened by the the
lack of electricity ukrainians are going
to freeze to death in great numbers in
their homes if more isn't done to help
them during what will be a very cold
miserable winter so he's going to be
asking for more Aid he's going to be
pressing members of Congress to support
the 37 37 billion dollars worth of Aid
that is currently in legislation going
through Congress and I think he will
hope to see off some of the grumblings
we've seen on the right of American
politics about how much help America is
giving Ukraine at a time when ordinary
Americans are suffering and need help uh
too I think we shouldn't overestimate
that but I think uh this PR this visit
will be used by the ukrainians and his
supporters in America to head off that
kind of opposition as this Brave Plucky
Ukrainian leader goes there and presses
his case in person for more help for
Ukraine during this war
okay Dominic for now thank you very much
for that
all right let's return now to the strike
action taking place today with thousands
of paramedics call handlers Emergency
Care assistants and technicians in
England and Wales walking out in a
dispute overpay let's bring in the
health secretary Steve Barkley who's
joining us now live from Westminster
good morning to you Secretary of State
thanks for being with me this morning
first let's just try and clear this up
what's your advice to the public today
if they need to call 999 I want an
ambulance sent well it's to use their
Common Sense the the system will be
under very severe pressure today the
trade unions have refused to give
National exemptions in terms of all
life-threatening and emergency calls
they've said that they will prioritize
those but they'll be down to local
agreements with trust and indeed some
decisions taken in call centers so the
system will be under significant
pressure and therefore we were saying to
the public to exercise their common
sense in terms of what activities they
do be mindful of the fact that those
pressures on the system and should local
decisions are they not the best ones to
take rather than having a plan is that
one of your concerns there is no
National contingency plan in place isn't
that your job well the difficulty of
putting constituency measures in place
is given the uncertainty as to what
exactly is and is not being covered and
the fact that those decisions in some
cases will be taken on the day but it's
also the case that even what's referred
to as Category 3
urgent calls of often very serious as
well so we're doing all we can with NHS
colleagues so put in place contingency
measures we've got the Army we've got
volunteers we've got community services
we've got frail elderly services in
terms of people that might fall so
there's a range of measures from a
contingency perspective that we've been
putting in place but there's obviously
limits to what that can be done and
therefore it is down to the trade unions
in terms of what exemptions they provide
and the concern is particularly if
services are taken from the picket line
that adds further confusion on the day
and potentially delays responses as I
could State you said in your piece this
morning in the the telegraph that the
only way to resolve this is by talking
the unions wants to talk to you they
keep saying that but they want to talk
to you about pay so why wouldn't you do
that well we have a process in terms of
pay an independent process and we've
accepted the recommendations in full and
that looks at both the pressures on the
NHS and indeed at the Autumn statement
additional funding was targeted to the
NHS the chancellor allocated an extra
6.6 billion pounds to the NHS but he
also put in place the biggest ever
increase in Social care funding an extra
7.5 billion pounds over the next two
years and that recognizes particularly
for paramedics one of the biggest issues
that raised with me when I was talking
to ambulance staff on Sunday evening
actually what they said to me was more
important than pay was the frustration
around Handover delays at hospitals and
they're often caused by the delay in
getting patients out of Hospital who are
fit to be discharged that's why the
chancellor invested the extra 7.5
billion pounds in Social care an extra
two hundred thousand social care
packages so we're investing in the NHS
we're investing in uh social care and I
don't want to divert money from those
essential Services focused on patients
uh to overturn what has been an
independent process which has looked at
what is Affordable to the economy what
is Affordable to your viewers at a time
or cost of living pressure but also
recognizing the systems under very
severe pressure and we need to get that
extra investment into the NHS and into
social care
uh we'll come back to some of the points
you make there in a moment section of
state but I just want to read you um
what's been said by the NHS providers
and NHS Confederation yesterday they
said that the fear of NHS leaders is
that the risk to patients is only going
to get worse with future strikes plants
that is unless the government is able to
reach agreement with the trade unions to
bring a swift end to the dispute now
that's not the union saying that that's
not nurses saying that that is the NHS
providers and this is on the government
on you to come to an agreement well we
have as I say accepted in full the
pay-per-view body recommendations but
that's in addition to last year let me
just let me just interrupt you there sir
I'm sorry to do that but you always talk
about the pay review bodies and you know
as well as I do that the pay review body
is not always listened to back in 2014
the pay review body recommended a one
percent increase in NHS pay that was
rejected by the now Chancellor Jeremy
Hunt in 2018 police officers were
recommended a pay review increase of two
percent that was rejected as well so you
can make a decision to not listen into
the pay-per-view body why are you not
doing it in this instance and when we
have done that you you've been the first
to I'm sure to to criticize us for not
respecting the independence the
difference here is we have accepted
those recommendations in full because we
recognize the system coming out of the
pandemic has been under pressure so we
have accepted the recommendations in
full and that comes on top of last year
when the rest of the public sector had a
pay freeze we prioritized the NHS with
an extra three percent rise when many
other people were facing a pay free so
we have prioritized uh the NHS we've
accepted in full the independent pay
review bodies recommendations but we've
gone further and we've put an extra 6.6
billion pounds into the NHS and the
record funding into social care because
we recognize the shoe strains the NHS is
in as a consequence of the pandemic and
it's important that we focus on those
patient services to clear the the
backlogs in operations to address the
Handover delays to get this poured into
primary care for GPS because that's
where the system is under most pressure
let me put let me put this to Mr Barkley
without having staff in the Health
Service because they're not being paid
they're not working in the right
conditions you won't be able to improve
those services and treatment outcomes
well it pay pay is a fact too I mean the
basic pay of a paramedic the average pay
of a paramedic is 34 300 but when you
add in overtime uh non-social ads that's
an extra 37 takes it up to 47
000 on top of that you get a 20 a fifth
uh going into pension as well so we have
listened to the recommendations of their
pay body on pay but pay is just one of a
number of factors we also look at the
fleet we're investing in more ambulances
we're putting more money into ambulance
trusts an extra 150 million pounds we're
also investing in call centers because
we've seen very significant increases in
pressure on the number of calls that
ambulance trusts are facing so we put an
extra 50 million pounds into that and as
well as that we recognize there's a
particular issue in terms of the elderly
those elderly uh people that fall the
need to get services to them that's why
we've been working with Partners like
Saint John's ambulance an extra 30
million in to get Saint John's ambulance
targeting those elderly fools so we're
investing more in the system we're doing
that within the context of an
independent process that looks at pay
but it's also important that we tackle
some of these system pressures
particularly around social care that's
why we put the record funding into that
and that in turn has a very big impact
on paramedics that is going to take a
while to feed through as you well know
now you mentioned in in the telegraph
today that uh striking workers are
taking a conscious decision to put
patients at risk that's not conciliatory
language that's not going to bring the
two sides closers together that's only
going to harden uh the side against you
isn't it well it's just a reflection of
fact the trade unions have chosen this
time for the strike we saw over the last
week a 73 increase in flu admissions to
hospital we saw a 27 increase in covid
emissions we've got five times the
normal prescribing rate of prescriptions
for antibiotics in terms of strep a
we've had a massive increasing calls to
111 up by more than a third we've got an
increase in calls to 999 over the last
month of 15 so the system is facing very
significant pressures as a result of flu
of covid of strep a and it's at this
time that trade unionism not only chosen
to strike but have refused to put in
place National exemptions to say they
will cover all of the life-threatening
and emergency cat one cat two calls that
in turn makes the contingency measures
much more difficult to play and I'm sure
the Unions would say that they're not
putting patients at risk you're actually
putting patients at risk by not willing
not being willing to discuss their pay
requests now this has been sold in
Scotland by meeting the pay requests of
uh striking staff there would the
government go to something like that
seven and a half percent for nurses to
try and resolve these strikes well one
of the big misconceptions about the the
deal in Scotland and incidentally the
GMB were opposed to the deal in Scotland
they're one of the trade unions that are
striking but it wasn't simply seven and
a half percent if you add in all the
other measures in terms of reducing
hours extra annual leave changes to the
way over time is address protected
learning time actually the cost of that
is much more significant and as I say
one of the trade unions has rejected
that as well but what we want to do is
focus on patience get that investment
into the NHS into social Care address
the blockage there are patients that are
ready to leave Hospital who is not in
their interest to stay so get that
social care and flow working that is
what we prioritized and we've done that
whilst also listening to what is an
independent process around the pay
review bodies we've accepted those
recommendations in full and that builds
on the extra three percent we awarded
last year at a time when other public
sector workers face to freeze
okay Steve Barkley uh thanks for being
with us
all right it's time for a look at what
the weather has in store for the next
couple of days and uh I don't think
we're gonna have a snowy white Christmas
as many people would have liked Let's uh
bring in our meteorologists Steph galter
who's joining us now live so stefa how's
it looking
well if we wanted a white Christmas we
should have moved it to last week and
then we would have seen some snow in
many places and it certainly would have
been cold that would have given us the
whiteness or the frost and Ice around
but as it is at the moment we've got an
area of low pressure to the Northwest
that's sucking up a load of very mild
air but it is looking like
uh we seem to have lost the line to us
Steph there Steph uh I bet it's not the
snow that's uh stopping you being able
to connect to Steph can you hear me okay
I can hear you fine oh excellent yeah
okay so I was just saying that we did
have lots of white weather last week but
unfortunately now we've got an area of
low pressure to our Northwest that's
sucking up a load of very very mild air
so it is just looking a bit soggy for
many of us currently it looks like that
low pressure is moving away though so
maybe for Christmas some of us might see
some wintry weather but I don't think
many of us let's have a look at the
forecast for today
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
so we've got our area of low pressure up
towards the Northwest then that's making
sure things are very very windy for many
of us in the Northwest and it's also
bringing in plenty of showers some of
those showers are heavy in the very
Northwest some of them are also with
thunder too and over the highest grounds
we're seeing a tiny bit of snow further
south where we have glorious blue skies
yesterday we're seeing more in the way
of bands of rain and those are tracking
their way southwards there's not one
here in Winchester at the moment but
there are plenty of them around they're
working their way Southwest but in
between them there is some sunshine and
wherever you are it is mild at the
moment with a top temperature today
expected of 12.
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
all right thank you very much Steph now
millions of people are out in the
streets of Buenos Aires last night
hoping to catch a glimpse of their World
Cup champions many managed to see the
squad as they drove by on an open top
bus but the parade was eventually
suspended after fans were seen doing
this jumping there you go from the
bridge to get on board the world Champs
are then transferred to a helicopter and
flew over the parade route now it is
reported that the festival atmosphere
changed as the evening went on with some
of the crowds clashing with police
now a standoff started when officers
began arresting fans who had broken into
the Obelisk stones and glass bottles
were thrown at the police who responded
with rubber bullets and mortar Cannon
hello you're watching at Sky News
breakfast our top stories this morning
thousands of ambulance staff are on
strike today only on this program the
health secretary accused workers of
walking out when the NHS is already
under pressure and said that he will not
be negotiating overpay
Ukraine's President Vladimir zelenski is
preparing to travel to Washington where
he's expected to meet President Biden
and the Scottish Parliament is expected
to give final approval today to
legislation making it easier for people
to legally change their recording gender
let's get more on those ambulance
strikes a few minutes ago the health
secretary told me that the walkout by
ambulance staff would cause significant
strain on the NHS he also held firm on
his position that the government will
not talk to NHS workers about pay
trade unions have chosen this time for
the strike we saw over the last week a
73 increase in flu admissions to
hospital we saw a 27 increase in covid
emissions we've got five times the
normal prescribing rate of prescriptions
for antibiotics in terms of strep a
we've had a massive increase in calls to
111 up by more than a third we've got an
increase in calls to 999 over the last
month of 15 so the system is facing very
significant pressures as a result of flu
of covid of strep a and it's at this
time that trade unionism not only chosen
to strike but have refused to put in
place National exemptions to say they
will cover all of the life-threatening
and emergency Cat 1 Cat 2 calls that in
turn makes the contingency measures much
more difficult
comparison National Secretary of the GMB
Union representing ambulance workers
Rachel Harrison good to have you with us
this morning so the health secretary
says that unions are making a conscious
decision to put patients at risk because
that's what's happening
good morning
um no I actually think that's a really
insulting statement to our key NHS and
ambulance workers they've not made a
conscious decision to put lives at risk
they've made a conscious decision to
stand up for what they believe is an NHS
that is crumbling beneath their feet and
as they're watching thousands of their
colleagues leave the service every year
because of poor pay and poor working
conditions and a feeling of being unable
to deliver the safe standards of patient
care that they want to that's why
they're making this conscious decision
and it is insulting to say that they're
doing this to put people at risk and as
you will have heard the health secretary
said that hundreds of millions have been
invested in the NHS to try and solve the
backlog he's saying that that is should
be enough and that's striking workers
really needs to get back to work
well we have to understand why there's
such a significant backlog and one of
the crucial reasons for that is the 133
000 Staffing vacancies that they are
across the NHS they were literally not
enough staff working in the NHS to
deliver on those services and without an
investment now in the workforce that we
have got now recruitment initiatives are
pointless we need to do everything we
can to protect our NHS workers that are
working in the system right now and that
that could be anyone from from Porters
and patient transport services to
paramedics to nurses we need to invest
in this Workforce Now
now the GMB as I understand it Rachel
Harrison haven't put forward a pay uh
demand uh why is that
well what we asked for when we entered
into the pay review body process in good
faith earlier this year was a
significant increase in Pay Plus a
commitment and a credible plan to
restore a decade of lost earnings and an
immediate down payment on that so that's
what we were asking for and that is what
we would still like to see but what
we're saying to the Secretary of State
and to this government right now is come
to the table talked to GMB talk to the
other health unions and make us an offer
on pay that we can take back to our
members I mean as you will have heard
the secretary of state is unwilling to
talk about pace so does that mean these
strikes are just going to go on
our members are the ones that will
decide what any future action may look
like but it's in the Secretary of
State's hands to end this dispute now
and by this government refusing to speak
to the unions about pay it is them that
are choosing that this dispute will
continue
just the last thought from you Rachel if
you can how how much longer on the
Mandate from this first vote have your
members got for the for the strike
action when do you have to go back to
them
under the Trade union legislations that
are currently in place
um unions have six months from securing
a ballot result for Action to take
action if the dispute continues longer
than that we have to run another ballot
okay Rachel Harrison from the GMP
appreciate your time this morning thank
you thank you
all right let's bring in Amanda our
political correspondent mad Acres
joining us from Westminster Amanda good
to have you back with us so we've seen
there the uh Secretary of State uh
sticking with his position that he will
not be discussing with the unions about
their payments
yes indeed and I think what we've heard
there from the two sides of the dispute
is that if anything there as far away as
they have ever been we heard Steve
Barkley accusing the unions um of taking
a conscious choice to infect harm on
patients and earlier he was telling you
um that um they have made a choice to
strike at this time of year when the NHS
is under its most significant strain as
a result of flu covid strep a and a
higher than usual rate of calls to
ambulance services and 999. he also
criticized the lack of what is called a
national exemption to the most
urgent calls this basically means
agreeing on paper that across the
country category one and Category 2
calls will always be answered the
Union's response to that is that they've
made agreements on a local level so that
is not necessary they've also also
accused the government of being
scaremongering and misleading in the way
they've talked about this lack of a
national agreement and indeed we just
heard there the GMB Union saying that
the government is being extremely
insulting to NHS workers by refusing to
come to the table and discuss pay at all
the government's sticking to that fairly
intractable line that they are sticking
with the findings of the independent pay
review giving workers around a four
percent increase the nurses of course
asking for a 19 increase ambulance
workers saying that they deserve
something above inflation they're not
putting a specific figure on it saying
that they want to negotiate and the
longer this goes on the government will
be more under more pressure to do so I
think okay Amanda for now thank you
all right now to the most significant
and perhaps controversial legislation
passed by Nicholas sturgeon since she
became first Minister making it easier
for people to change their legal gender
the Scottish government wants to
simplify and speed up the existing
process unlike at present no formal
diagnosis of gender dysphoria or medical
reports would be required the period in
which applicants need to live in their
new gender will be cut from two years to
three months or six months for 16 and 17
year olds who will now be allowed to
obtain a gender recognition certificate
previously the age limit was 18.
or joining us now from Edinburgh is the
SNP at MSP Karen Adam good morning to
you Karen and thanks for being with us
this morning so just explain to us why
the Scottish government is attempting to
change the law here
well it's not actually giving trans
people any ex more rights what it's
doing is simplifying a process that's
already in place to ensure that trans
people can obtain a gender recognition
certificate it demedicalizes the process
it takes away the need for strangers on
a panel to make decisions about an
individual that they've never met and
this is in fact a really good news story
this is progression in Scotland making
it a more fairer and equal place to live
and that can only be a good thing let's
explain to us why it's important to take
medical professionals out of this
process because this is obviously a
hugely significant decision that an
individual could be making
absolutely there's no need for this to
be medicalized trans people know their
own minds they know and understand what
they want to do with their lives they
have bodily autonomy and that should be
honored absolutely
I mean how do you answer the criticism
that this uh clarification of the
legislation as you put it is is in fact
harmful to the rights of women
absolutely well not there there is no
um there's no way that women's rights
are going to be impacted by this I'm a
woman myself I'm an intersectional
feminist and this in fact is good for
feminism overall is good for women
because this is progression away from
archaic systems and of course we have to
remember that trans women are women as
well and we're all in this fight of
feminism together there there should be
no conflation with anything else this is
about trans people and a process to
simplify them obtaining a gender
recognition certificate to live their
lives with dignity and respect but just
just staying on the rights of women this
decision has been criticized by the
special rapporte on violence against
women and girls from the United Nations
I mean she's an expert in the field and
she's concerned about the changes well
we've had I'm a member of the equality
human rights and Civil Justice committee
and we had an Evidence session on Monday
which we were able to speak to two are
of the UN Specialists and Victor was
there as well and I did ask her
um probably about three times to ask why
she changed her mind away from
supporting the model of self-id and
simplifying the process for Trans people
but what she did was write a letter to
Bulgaria in 2021 asking them to do that
um after three questions I really
couldn't quite get to the bones of the
evidence of to why she would have
changed her mind and Victor himself had
provided quite a lot of
evidence-based facts so for myself or
the other members of the committee for
the months of time we've taken on
evidence sessions on this you know I'm
very satisfied that there is no threat
to women and girls absolutely not and it
shouldn't be conflated with that yeah
it's not just a screaming in the U.N
that was disagreement within your own
parties isn't as well uh Miss Adam but
also let's just go back to the idea of a
16 or 17 year old making such a huge
decision on their lives I mean I know
remember I was like at 16 is it really
the time to be making such a huge
profound life-changing decisions without
the support of professionals
yeah well I mean I mean just to pick up
on other members of the SNP group you
know it's a very small vocal minority
and that is done for them to to answer
for that we were elected on a Manifesto
commitment twice to past gender
recognition reform we took evidence from
the Scottish children's commissioner who
advised that lowering the age to 16 and
17 would be a good thing we're talking
about people who are going to be
transitioning out of schools academies
into perhaps the workforce into further
education and to be able to have a
certificate in their gender and with
their their name that they want to be
called by is crucially important for
them and for their mental health and for
them to be able to take part in society
as the person that they know and want to
be
okay Karen Adam appreciate your time
this morning thank you no worries thank
you
all right this is Sky News breakfast and
still to come we'll take a closer look
at some of the stories making headlines
in our paper review
all right time for a look through the
morning's newspapers now joined by the
journalist North at Janelle aldrid and
by the academic and writer Joanna
Williams Joanna Janelle good to have you
both back with us let's dive straight
into this and we're going to a story
that you've picked out Joanna or rather
reporting you've picked out inside pages
of the Daily Mirror let's just bring up
a double page spreadshe and this is all
about the pressures on the NHS hell on
the 999 front line tell us about this
yeah I think this is a really important
story that the mirror is covering here
and it's actually taking us um beyond
the issue of pay in terms of what these
strikes are about and sadly some of
these stories we have become familiar
with of pensioners
um who take a fall and are then left are
cold on the pavement perhaps even
outside
um for very very long periods of time
and this is about paramedics arriving
too late I mean it's really tragic
arriving too late to patients who've
um called for an ambulance or their
relatives have called for an ambulance
and the pressure that's placed on
paramedics who then have to turn around
and explain to relatives that they're
terribly sorry but there's just nothing
they can do and I do think this is
important for a number of reasons I mean
mainly because it shows us that these
strikes are about more than than just
pay they are about the conditions in the
NHS as well
um but I actually think it's it's really
important that there is a bit of a more
of a national conversation we really
about what is going on in the NHS other
than as we say just the issue of pay we
need to look at why patients are who are
clinically well and not able to be
discharged into Care Homes we need to
look at where the money is going within
the NHS I think because
um if you compare the money that goes
into our NHS with other
um countries in Europe we don't actually
fall that far behind we don't have the
lowest rates of funding and yet we do
have worse outcomes in a number of areas
my concern is that we have far too much
bureaucracy by too many managers far too
many people who are working in backroom
roles who don't necessarily contribute
to the health of patients on the front
line now clearly some of those are going
to be very important I'm not suggesting
uh we ditch all managers in the NHS but
I think actually having a proper
conversation about what we expect of the
NHS and how it can serve the country
better I think it's absolutely vital
thank you for that Joanna and Janelle
you're picking up a story inside the
Telegraph and this is
um about some of the services that may
well be lost as a result of these
strikes tell us about this
so one of the things that is being lost
is home birth to being scrapped because
of Transport fears that if things go
wrong when someone's having a home birth
and they wouldn't be able necessarily to
get an ambulance to get them to the
hospital quickly and safely I'm an
ambassador for sounds of stillbirth and
neonatals our society and you know of
course in moments like these and and
it's hard because it's a choice that
women want to make for themselves about
where they give birth how they Access
Health Care and that is being taken away
and there are things being taken away
and it does feel hard but as we spoke
about in the last hour the point of
strikes are to be disruptive the point
of strikes are to push the point home
but the way things are working are not
working and we need to find some new
ways to work just like Joanna said we
need to think about what is the NHS here
for what services should it be providing
how do we make sure that it gives first
class care to people and I was having a
conversation with someone the other day
and they said the NHS seems very
reactive and not proactive in terms of
when it comes to health care and how we
access it so I think there are many many
conversations to be had but I feel like
I've almost been driven into a private
Health Care situation because things
will get so bad that people will just
begin to start self-selecting out of the
NHS and I think that would be a massive
shame okay uh Janelle thanks for that
Joanna let's move on to this story that
you picked out here interesting
reporting in inside the The Daily Mail
and this is about support for striking
workers uh just lay out uh what this
latest poll tells us
yeah so it shows that there's some quite
big disparities really in the public
support for nurses uh compared to the
train drivers for example
um I actually think having public
support is really important for the
strikers and I think the union leaders
must bear this in mind and I don't think
that means backing down on strikes but I
do think it means um being available for
media interviews for example and and
actually making the case so things like
that article in the mirror that we were
just talking about really pointing out
why these strikes are important and
what's at stake here and how this I
think even arguing for a pay rise it's
very important because it's not just
about the the workers who are
um kind of going to immediately benefit
but it's about the living standards of
workers more broadly of everybody in
society and the idea of not accepting
wages that we can't afford to feed our
families off I think that's very very
important principle
um but I do think it the levels of
support for the next is in particular I
do seem to be extremely high and I think
that's heartening it's saying 66 percent
of the public are in favor of Vanessa's
striking and even among conservative
party voters more people are supporting
the nurses than than are not and and I
think they really the union really needs
to make sure that that remains the case
um support has still has fallen slightly
it's suggesting uh for people who are
for the train drivers
um and the rail workers but but the
figures are still fairly High you know
now like I said I do think it's
important that the union leaders
capitalize on this and and continue to
make uh the bigger arguments about why
these strikes are important yeah thanks
that John and I do want to just move on
you know if you can forgive me but I
want to stick with Johnny because I do
want to pick up the story that Joanna's
picked out here in the Daily Telegraph
we just reported it earlier by speaking
to Karen Adam this is about those gender
uh recognition reforms Joanna you picked
out
um how the Daily Telegraph are covering
it just just tell us what the paper is
saying
yeah so it's pointing out the fact that
our children and I I use that word very
pointedly children at the age of 15 will
begin to start the process of changing
their gender so that they can then apply
for uh gender recognition certificate in
the opposite sex to that they were born
as um on their 16th birthday essentially
I've said as a mother of a 16 year old
daughter This concerns me greatly
um we do not let 16 year olds buy
cigarettes we do not let 16 year olds
buy alcohol and I think there are very
good reasons why as a society we've made
that decision that 16 ul's aren't
allowed to do those things uh you know
when I was 16 I I changed my mind from
one day to the next about the type of
person I was what I was into and the
idea that people can make such
potentially a life-altering decisions at
this very very young age I think should
really concern all of us I don't think
it's a positive thing I don't think it's
a progressive thing I also think it's
incredibly disingenuous to say that this
demand equalizes the process because we
know from statistics from research
that's been done in this area that
social transition that means just being
able to change your name your pronouns
your style of dress is highly likely
there's a very very strong correlation
uh with young people who make that step
to socially transition who do that go on
things we are running short time just to
be completely clear is at the age of 16
and it's not a transition yet it's a
gender recognition it's a certificate
isn't it so it's not a medical process
but but social transition okay John
thank you very much Janelle we'll come
back to you again in the next I do
appreciate you both guys for being with
us thank you so much